Speaker 1: We had every reason to believe
that very soon Matt Gates and his crime story
would be back in the news.
And it has just exploded back into the news
as Gates associate Joel Greenberg has now
pleaded guilty to six federal crimes, including
sex trafficking of 18, exactly the same crime
that Matt Gates is being investigated for.
Now, as a reminder, Joel Greenberg is a former
tax collector in Florida, Seminole County.
When we learned that this Joel Greenberg decided
to cooperate with investigators, Greenberg's
lawyer, Fritz Scheller, held a hilarious press
briefing outside a courthouse and was straight
up asked, Did your client, Joel Greenberg,
introduce Matt Gates to underage girls and
check out the then hilarious response from
Greenberg's lawyer.
Unidentified: You're asking for any kind of.
So I'm just going to
Speaker 3: let you sit down there so I can
look over your head and ignore that question.
I apologize.
I just can't answer that question.
I was one of those that was a little devious
sliding down there below and maybe using that
it means, you know, so.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, it's looking very,
very bad.
Again, six guilty pleas for Joel Greenberg,
a sex trafficking, a minor I.D. theft, stalking
and fraud.
And again, remember, we learned a couple of
weeks ago about a letter sent by Joel Greenberg
to Roger Stone admitting that he introduced
Matt Gates to young girls, the six charges
that Greenberg has pled guilty to.
That's down from 33 charges.
We can only imagine it's six instead of 33
because of his cooperation, which should be
very scary for Congressman Matt Gates.
Now, on the sex trafficking of a minor charge,
the specific admission is that Greenberg admits
to recruiting women for commercial sex acts
and paying them more than seventy thousand
dollars between 2016 and 2018.
This is quickly getting very ugly for Matt
Gates.
And the only question now is if and when Gates
will get indicted.
Some people called into the show last week
and said, David, of course, Gates is getting
indicted.
I'm not sure.
And we'll get back to that.
Gates has, of course, denied all wrongdoing.
And on the Friday show this week, I'm going
to talk a little bit about do sexual assault
allegations matter any more in politics?
Do they matter to Democrats but not to Republicans,
or do they not matter at all at this point
in time?
We're going to talk about that Friday.
Maybe in this case, Republicans should go
sort of with the Trump riot's defense.
Remember how Trump has said, you know, it
wasn't real?
Trump is riding on January 6th.
That was like antifa in disguise or something.
Maybe they go with Matt Gates is really antifa
in disguise.
Matt Gates isn't really a Republican.
I don't know.
It's important to remember, though, that if
you were Joel Greenberg, you do not plead
guilty even to the six charges, never mind
33, unless you really are had dead to rights
by investigators, you are setting yourself
up, at least potentially for some serious
prison time by pleading guilty.
You do not plead guilty to sex trafficking
of a minor unless you have figured out a way
to get leniency by informing about others
or something.
Now, in all seriousness, are we going to get
accountability?
Because for the last several weeks, Gates
almost seems emboldened by this investigation.
He's been running around doing these America
first tour events, promoting all sorts of
election lies, writing off this entire investigation
as some kind of partizan witch hunt, which
he conveniently fails to mention that the
investigation started under Donald Trump.
Donald Trump's Justice Department started
looking at Gates, but was stonewalled by political
appointees to the Justice Department who were
political appointees of Donald Trump.
So it's a story with so much of what's wrong
right now, two tiered justice system, cronyism,
belligerent arrogance, hypocrisy, double standards.
It's everything.
Let's now see if there is accountability.
I hope that there is last week or the week
before, I said I don't know if Gates is going
to end up indicted.
I got a few calls and even played a voicemail
from one caller who said, David, I don't know
if you're just trying to be balanced, but
of course, Matt Gates is getting indicted.
I'm not so sure.
Let's see if there is accountability.
It seems as though the leash is starting to
tighten and we're going to continue following
it.
We will have more coverage of the Matt Gates
fiasco on our Instagram, which you can find
at David Pakman show.
If you want to see video of my garden.
If you want a break from politics, check out
my really intense lettuce.
Yes.
Let you see on my Instagram David Pakman.
Find me their quick break.
Back after this.